did you see the video the lady that's
like that guy's not real
did you read what she claimed she saw
what no she saw a man in a green hoodie
blink vertically
if there was a seat open beside that guy
and he was a lizard I'd be like whatever
as long as I'm not [__] in the middle
up here yeah I'm taking the aisle for
sure
you're like word yeah you [__] lock
this guy up you are weird and you're
like I bet you like this and you just
angle your reading light tones put some
heat on that skin you are scaly my man
lotion or something
or some shot [__] live mouse I want
to see it go down thank you oh my god
oh damn that shit's just for him
[__] [__] you can believe that or you
can choose not to believe that but I
don't know what that chick was talking
about he's definitely real real [__]
weird real real weird you are an animal
my man literally love you you're a
[__] freak